as a result of the worst blunder of his
14 years in power lineman Putin has
forever changed the geostrategic map of
Europe the fate of the Ukrainian
revolution and of Ukraine's march
towards Europe will now be decided in a
strategic triangle between Ukraine's
domestic politics the Western powers EU
and the US and Russia the main danger
for Ukraine is infighting between the
leaders of the revolution it is a relief
to learn that Yulia Tymoshenko a former
prime minister now released from jail
has understood that her train as they
say in Ukraine has left the station
perhaps she could mediate between the
leaders of the revolution the second
danger is attention between the eastern
part of Ukraine which is Russia looking
and Russia speaking and the western part
which is Ukrainian speaking and looks
towards Europe the Western powers EU and
the US now must help the revolution a
big loan appears to be in the works and
the IMF and the World Bank seem to be
engaged this is a good first step Russia
has a big problem for months perhaps
years to come the key goal of Russian
domestic and foreign policy is likely to
be to minimize the impact of the
revolution in Ukraine to contain it and
perhaps to destabilize it domestically
to counter the effect of the revolution
there's likely to be an upsurge of
repression and propaganda in the end
though the enormous change made by the
Ukrainian revolution in the political
configuration of Eurasia is not likely
to change the mole of history which was
Marxist image for progress has burned
its way very close to Russia's borders
you